I have some circles today and they're
made of brass and the wonderful thing
about circles as we all know is they
roll which is why as an invention
they're up there just behind fire and a
head of sliced bread so if I set this
going in theory say that right rolls
right across the table
and the reason a circle rolls and sorry
if I'm breaking this down a bit too much
is because as it moves its center of
mass so if I draw that over here I
better for you funny I had a template I
could have drawn around as a circle
rolls its center of mass stays at that
same height which is why if I tried to
roll a square I've got a square here
there's its center of mass in the middle
as it rolls the center of mass has to go
up and then it has then it goes down
right and so up and then down so it will
roll but you've got to you've got to
drive it you've got to be constantly
forcing it because when it's here at
center of mass is there but then if it
lifts up the center of mass is it has
gone up so this that will stay the same
whereas you turn a square the center of
mass has to be raised then I think about
a circle is you have to have to drive it
because we've got friction and you know
as always we live in a messy physical
reality but the actual center of mass
doesn't go up or down so that means it
rolls quite neatly it's not the only way
you can roll a circle so a center of
mass stays at the same height I've got
two circles here and they've both got
notches cut into them and that means I
can slot them together now they are
brass and they really grip quite let me
just make sure I got that right in I've
now got to firmly locked together
circles and they're at right angles that
are thuggin or to each other and if I
put them down the center of mass is kind
of well probably there ish and it's a
certain height above the table the
amazing thing is as it rolls that center
of mass stays at exactly the same height
yeah
the center of mass of each individual
circle because circles are quite
predictable it's in the middle because
I've got some cardboard one so the
center of mass we can draw it on in fact
it's got a picture of the disks on the
disk which I find hugely entertaining so
that's the center of the mass is there
the middle that kind of makes sense
because it's you know the same distance
away that's the you know symmetric
center of that circle when you got two
of them together I guess a bit more
complicated and so now you think well
where's the exact center of this and you
can calculate it which I did just to be
thorough or you can just say look
symmetrically where's the that is the
point there that that point right in
there is the kind of symmetric point
right in the center of all the mass
which is why we give it the strange name
the center of mass and so as long as
that spot stays the same height above
the surface this nice flat table then
you're not adding or receiving or taking
out any potential energy as it rolls so
that's why if this is just the right
intersection and that dot stays the same
height above the table that's why you
get the rolling effect there we go
if you want to make these yourself then
you see I made them by cutting a notch
into a piece so cars easier you can make
them out of CDs or anything else these
are made of brass
so they roll a bit nicer but they're a
bit harder to machine up but if you want
to make something yourself you want to
make that cut and you want to work out
how far in you have to cut for the whole
thing to work and you can calculate
mathematically what you have to do in
fact the easiest way to do the maths
which is of course why we're here is to
consider when you put them together the
center of this disc so that's the exact
middle of that disc there that's the
middle of that disc there normally
that'd be if we didn't have grooves in
them they would sit like that and so
that's the radius of this disc that's
the radius of this disc and so the
center's would be 2 times the radius
apart at all times by having those slots
though they get closer together and the
question is how far apart are these two
centers now that we've put the slots in
there so that height doesn't change and
we can work that out with some triangles
so here we go now there are two
important states we have to worry about
with the wobbler disc and one is when
you're looking at it perfectly end on
and they're both 45 degrees to the
surface so that's that position there
which I'm going to draw end on here
there so that that's that's you know
looking at it that way straight down so
the center of mass is there it is now
we're going to call this the height
above the table that there is the radius
of the disks and that there is at 45
degrees or PI on 2 depending on what you
want to say I mean you could say that is
tau on 4 but then you'd be an idiot so
if because that's 45 it means this here
is also the same as the height because
we have a wonderful 45 45 right angle
triangle there and so we know using our
friend Pythagoras that r-squared equals
H squared plus 8 squared which equals to
H squared and so if we take a square
root of that
we know the radius equals square root of
two times eight so that's our ratio in
that position the important thing is we
want that H to stay exactly the same
height even when it's rolling so once
it's rolled for a bit and it ends up in
that position so now you've got one disk
coming straight up and the other one is
pretty much well it's not flat flat but
you know what I mean there so that
sketch that so we got one disc like that
and then there's the center now that
Center is going to cut line down to the
surface and there's going to be the
other disk there like that okay so
that's in that position so once again
there is the center of that disk there
there's a center of that disk there what
we want to calculate is this distance
that the center's are apart so that's d
the distance we want to know because
that tells us how big to make the
notches so that they sit at the right
distance and that D we can calculate
because we know that's the center down
to where it touches that must be the
radius of that disc and this here that
height there must be the radius because
it's the circle standing straight up the
center of mass is there which is halfway
between the two centers and that is the
H which is all-important and that
distance there from that Center to there
well that's half of this so that little
distance there that's D on to because
it's half of that distance and so now we
can use our good friends similar
triangles which means that for this
small triangle here so to get from the
bottom to there that's R plus D on two
divided by H equals the big triangle
which is R plus D over ah all right so
now we're off and racing all we have to
do is solve this to work out what D is
we want to get rid of that annoying H
there but we know from over here that H
equals R divided by root 2 so we can
substitute that in over here so that now
becomes R + D on 2 over r over
route 2 and that still equals R plus G
ah to tidy this up a little bit I'm
going to multiply both sides by r
because it's going to cancel out with
these ones underneath and so that ends
up being root 2 outside of our plus D on
2 equals R plus D and to get rid of this
mess at the front here I'm going to
multiply both sides by root 2 so from
our by this by root 2 I get a 2 at the
front so that becomes 2r plus D because
at 2 cancels with the 1/2 and humbled by
this by root 2 I get root 2 R plus root
2 D and now I can put all the same terms
on the same side so this one if I
subtract that root 2 at D from both
sides I get 1 D minus the root 2 outside
of D equals and I subtract the 2 are
from both sides that's going to be root
2 minus 2r if I made any mistake I've
probably made a mistake in there
somewhere so all we want to do now is
work out the ratio that D is compared to
the radius and so we have to do is
rearrange this to get D in terms of r
and because i know where we're going and
because i'm picking a very careful path
through the algebraic you know field we
could be working our way across I mean
if you try this if you set up different
triangles you did it all these steps
differently you still get the same
answer at the end because that's why
mass is wonderful followed by both sides
by 1 plus root 2 1 times 1 is 1
and so we're going to multiply that by
that as well we leave 2 times 1 is going
to be minus 2 so they're cancel out
that's lovely
and so all of this has shown us that the
wobbling discs work only when those two
centers are root 2 times the radius of
the disks apart there are far more
complicated ways through this terrain
but no matter what you do no matter what
algebra you're dancing around with long
as you're careful it everything drops
out at the very end it's so lovely
matter what you do everything settles
and cancels out and you always end up
with root 2 times the radius and I love
the fact that such a quite a complicated
system and a decent amount of math to
get there is such a nice simple neat
answer and that for me is mathematics
first time I did this I didn't work out
that distance between the centers I
worked out because I'm a pragmatic man
at heart
actually I went forth as a heart because
they're really wedged in as a pragmatic
man I worked out what is that distance
there so I did that calculation to try
and calculate that and you can work it
out now either you can work backwards
from this or I can just ruin the
surprise and tell you that that distance
there is 1 minus 1 over root 2 times the
radius so in fact if you want to make
one of these and for once I will
actually sketch one properly so there's
your disk and that's got some radius are
that distance there is 1 minus 1 over
root 2 times whatever that radius R is
if you're a lazy person that is about
29% that is point to 9 times the radius
give or take 29% 29% that's where it is
about it's about 1/3 but if you wanted
to work really well then you need to go
for point 2 9 times the radius or you
can work it out if you want to here and
see even more mathematics from Matt
Parker more than we could ever fit in a
hundred numberphile videos he's got a
new book out things to make and do in
the fourth dimension here the front
covers of the book in the UK and the
United States you can already order it
from wherever you normally get books or
if you want a copy hand signed by Matt
himself go to his website and I'm going
to put the links in the video
description I think if you get the one
signed by Matt you're going to get the
UK one no matter where you live check it
out people like Matt give loads of time
to numberphile we filmed this video on a
Sunday afternoon when you could have
been out with family and friends there's
not much we can do in return but
checking out his book is one of those
things and don't do it just to be nice
do it because it's an excellent book and
worth reading